[Music]
texting me cumin seed on a laptop
Johanna eager maintain and Oleg
augmentin kwang-ho TSLA no legal mean
kangaroos on how tanga tanga tanga who
said my mark on her hand on can engage
of same in the future enjoy geology or
high year twins and we can all mundo
Holly coca sang even without luggage or
to pay for government of Texas already
so lot of Shama out of the handgun so
Kimmy so they can find a taxi meter he
car or the legal car dropped out tangelo
negatory and Tom no such anger song I
took singing munication it illegal me
come to sing me wouldn't assume you know
that I locked up send out your help in a
look come on welcome chok chok
sangam-dong agenda means and chosen a
cow like alchemy invented narrator
William Nagato from the atom in button
Rock Island ok who call meaning to
nobody can't another will tell you that
you stronger you can Singapore manager -
become nuts on each occasion Edo Tokyo
unconverted informant consuming oil my
angel my diamond I took singing higher
course at shinagawa Rico even song I
have phase until your toilet talk I
think I will
such diamond my hotel soda he got
bombing us here how high we got a lotion
get to low shrinkage either high or Seco
rock ACH all sahaja top things on being
a see how my pipe with oil chosen a
little paper high-technology the Hogan
like how human we are see uneven
technical and so toxin and a Paula told
jihad helices also Antonio decoder ha
how you bad bad seize him
Alex you junkie comes out high or they
saw you go to talk singing me I hung a
contract I'll get what a [ __ ] him mom
so take honey I mean it o ye turned a
coffee shop you know how you catch up
junior high
tell him I'm coming door hang on yeah
times econ don't know I catch up I said
what they call come they don't get me
[Music]
there is a wise old Japanese saying the
nail that sticks out gets hammered down
well down in Tokyo there's one nail that
sticks out just about as far as you can
imagine an inventor known across the
country a mad genius with a staggering
number of patents ton Django have been
imagining hey Gavin yeah Thomas Alva
Edison or somebody up that includes a
wig for self-defense meet you Shiro
Nakamatsu you may notice his name is
spelled mahkumat he dropped the letter
you because he says an eight-letter name
is easier to remember but he still wants
you to pronounce it you got a duck dr.
Nakamatsu score key inventions brought
him worldwide recognition inventions
like the peon peon booths with springs
that put an extra bounce in your step
there's dr. Nakamatsu siree Breck's
it looks like a lazy boy but the doc
says the darn thing enhances brainpower
then there's the gold golf putter that
pays when you strike the ball
huh would you look at that you know
you've made it when the streets are
named after you but make no mistake dr.
Nakamatsu his inventions aren't all
noisy golf clubs and bouncy shoes he
claims to have invented the floppy disk
that's right that floppy disk
retractable landing gear a widely used
kerosene pump and even the digital watch
to maintain his hyper creativity dr.
Nakamatsu keeps his mind and body in
shape that lightweight inventor Thomas
Edison said genius is 1% inspiration and
99% perspiration is that your secret dr.
Nakamatsu Eurasian de nuestro dozle
khodataeva con todas scene oh yeah
static guru matter camel toe toe toe
cabinet general changes national Abba
tere bin Laden Patoka Jeon abandon them
Pakistan is say hi Donna Donna yes
no quieres kono dynamic comedy that's my
new motto me Noah it's more Beethoven
Daigo no dice and actual started as
Muhammad Amadeus sir a demo domina by
erroneously Aquanaut anonymous wreckage
of the diary my optimism missus no not
animal to Horace
[Music]
miss Donna Panama nematoda sans Oona
nonny Marin economist cameo at mesh mesh
day soryo Montecito el amor de NOS dejas
OH - Tesoro memin todo y todo at Emma's
cinema no date Enrico biomat ago tow
miss Newman tonight Oh sighs Oh Tina
zona de Nino day sinico hots researcher
dr. Cotterill chilly O'Connor Hodgman
horse texture is your name is Jesse
Grahm grad master at actua attending
college - master dr. Nakamatsu saw the
cancer as an opportunity it was his
greatest challenge to invent his way out
of an impossible corner he developed his
own personal cancer treatment
this includes a meticulously documented
diet and a new invention to fight the
cancer
II called the Gangan robe
the doctors gave him one year to live
that was five years ago
[Music]
but actua quue sudesna este lo siento a
moto de maison what actua rocket so stay
services - Tina Choi Hyun Joo sang not a
tequila solo so no sir no ganado simple
nada mucho mas ANCA demo add actua
cinema de anza meiosis guru - Oh nanana
attack Shiva Street Oh No Sergio
Mortimer Tata Tata Motel therapist
selenium they attack us yes
[Music]
a legend around this chalk is that it's
impossible to write a false theorem
I assume the special ingredients or
angel tears mathematicians from all the
top schools very frequently use it
it's a cult favorite as soon as I used
it I was a convert the chalk is one of
the best-kept secrets in the math world
it's the rolls-royce of truck hog Oromo
is a brand of Japanese chalk the way it
flows on a board is a bit hard to
describe in words it's really hard to
get only get it from Japan you need a
Japanese person to bring it back for you
I discovered it when I went to visit the
University of Tokyo and one of the
professor's there said to me you know we
have better chalk than you do in the
States and I said oh go on chalk his
chalk and so I tried it out and I was
surprised to find that he was right I
tried it I thought was phenomenal it's
the densest it erases the cleanest that
leaves the nicest line if you use bad
chalk often you're depressed really hard
for anyone to see what you're writing
so using hagoromo on a good board it
doesn't really feel like you're working
hard to write when I'm teaching I get a
feeling of energy confidence and the
chalk absolutely helps slowly the math
world has become aware of this and it
became a bit of a fad in some circles
[Music]
it was like maybe four years ago the
word came out that the company was going
out of business
I sort of jokingly referred to it as a
chalk apocalypse so I immediately
started hoarding up as much as I could I
order three boxes of hagoromo and kept
in my office and used it very sparingly
I should have bought more but I have
friends that bought boxes and boxes and
boxes of the stuff they might very well
be set for the rest of their career
without like 1506
that's a lot of days for sticks a day I
think I'm gonna make it I have probably
a 10 year supply still at home but
calculated how many boxes what I needed
to last for 10 or 15 years I didn't want
to become a talk to you later but I did
like the idea that I could be the first
stick is free chalk dealer on the block
in my department I was probably selling
it regularly to maybe eight to ten
colleagues I would reach into my
cupboard in my office and pull out
another box and we do the deal in my
office that we all had a chalk fix and
we still do the original hygroma chalk
is slowly disappearing a few years ago a
Korean company bought their formulas and
did the best job of faithfully
reproducing and agree it was mixed
emotions I was happy to know that it
would still be made but I was a little
disappointed that I was less clever than
I thought I was
in many ways mathematics is like
craftsmanship in some ways it's like
artistry in some ways it's like science
but there's a real toy craft side to
giving a beautiful lecture on a
blackboard mathematicians admire this in
each other and like to use the best
tools for it there's incredible value to
this but the value isn't using it up not
hoarding it
[Music]
to cook a good dish
you need a few things good ingredients
sharp knives and time in this restaurant
they have a stew I've just been cooking
for well a really really really really
long time
[Music]
hallelujah what a nap I need come from
to another home career in a walk-up this
isn't your normal Bangkok Bistro
they have been serving the same beef
stew for nearly five decades no not the
same recipe literally the same soup
same giant pan same broth same soup sigh
hey Tina to know love until your name
here ha ha no - no no no that's on you
and I'm so chill out you play Muhammad
is happy
- Amira - Kamala have Nokia Martin would
see you happy - what Laura may be
militant employer to keep wiping the
company or by using an ancient cooking
method known in some cultures as hunters
stew this award-winning broth becomes
tastier the longer you cook it so [ __ ]
off he lost hi Nene I'm so quick anatomy
hung Neptune Nassau looks in lockup of
the Kenai book in Africa poss-eye
top which Iraqi Louisville a while which
I some honey suit unum to follow up he
got a thong on soy Paco California but
to me names of [ __ ] / nama saya now you
might be asking what's that ring around
the pan well that is 45 years of broth
spill over think of it as a tradition
- Annie Lamott an infinite Cup in Turkey
- AHA boom naughty young Shin Kamiya
Berta in chip in kuntum maja Newton's
how hop
la quwata me from my lips Wonka on
biting Gandhian have lobotomy playa
mr. Foy doula Coco pommel and so on top
of being pin bloody farm
kogami lumen gonca hua hua lu han
seung-wan damage we can do liability
theater viable and now the most
important part that enticed
delicious